can Sean Strickland with his Philly
shell style fighting and not a knockout
artist can that style that limited style
good enough not for Izzy to figure out
in 25 minutes and land a bomb the odds
in history say no I think what it what
is is Izzy a minus 600 he's a heavy
favorite minus 600 Yeah Izzy should
probably be again this is no disrespect
this is very black and white just
analytical thinking Izzy should probably
be somewhere in the ballpark of minus
2000 when you look at his chances of
figuring out Izzy who again he has 20
world class moves that you've never seen
he's competed against much better
Strikers in glory and then MMA he's seen
this style he's seen a Apollo Costa
style who again a lot of pressure but a
little more power than Strickland right
and he's navigated that he he's figured
out that that kind of pace he's he's
seen it before I I think minus 2000
probably more realistic